So here's an algorithm that you'd probably either already know about or would be
able to come up with rather quickly. Which is the idea of hill climbing. So
if this is the function that we're trying to find the maximum of, then
one thing we could do is imagine just guessing some x, I don't know, say,
Which has some particular f of x value, and then
to say, okay, well, let's move around in a neighborhood around
that point, and see where we can go that would actually
improve the function value. So we, here the neighborhood might be,
you know, a little to the left, a little to
the right on the x axis, and, what we find in
one direction it's going down and the other direction it's going
up. So what hill climbing says is find the neighbor that
has the largest function value. This is steepest ascent hill
climbing. And if that neighbor is above where we are now,
has a higher function value than we are now then move
to that point. Otherwise, we stop because we are at a
local optimum. So, what this is going to do is it's going to
iterate moving up and up and up and up this curve,
always in a better and better and better direction until it
hits this peak here. Then, it's going to look on both sides
of it. The neighborhood, everything in the neighborhood is worse.
So, it just stops there and this is the x
that it returns. Which is, you know, not bad answer.
It's not the best answer. But, it's a good answer.
>> Hm. What if you had started out just a little bit
more to the left? Say, on the other side of that valley.
>> Oh, like here?
>> Yeah.
>> Hm. So then, well, let's
see. What would it, what would it do? We start there.
We take a step. We, we say, what's the neighborhood? The neighborhood
or the points, just a little bit to the left, and
just a little bit to the right. One of them is an
improvement. So it takes the improvement. And again, it keeps finding
it more and more improved. And then it gets to this top
of this little bump and it says, okay, both the points in
my neighborhood are worse than where I am now. Hurray, I'm done.
>> Hm.
>> So, that's not even worst of the local optima,
you could actually get stuck here as well, which is even lower.
>> Well, you could get stuck anywhere. Well, at any peak.
>> Yes, exactly right and that's the lowest of the peaks.